5 55 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about three
complaints in one viewer beverly
boy she's got a lot on her mind first
she's complaining about speed she writes
please slow down on ulta
charleston and far hills and the 215 and
summer parkway in the morning that's
like the indianapolis 500.
second out of state plates she writes
either go home
or learn to obey our speed limit you're
not in california anymore
register your vehicle the dmv is open
but there's more
third she's got a twist on drinking and
driving saying to
bartenders don't serve drunk people
beverly you're preaching to the choir
speeding
never a good idea we'll continue to
bring up unregistered plates to
police and nhp and i would hope that
bartenders can
err on the side of caution when it comes
to cutting off customers but what do you
do
when drunk drivers were their own
bartenders in the comfort of their own
homes
thanks again for riding buckle up drive
carefully please put down the phone if
there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com